vous inquiétez pas trop et entre bonnes
mains ils vont s'en occuper
d'accord
allez
[Musique]
pas facile
à peine
c'est très dur
tout petit je rêvais d'aider les autres
sauvé secourir protéger finalement j'ai
changé de cap je suis journaliste et
j'ai décidé d'aller à la rencontre de
ces hommes et de ses femmes ordinaires
qui exercent des métiers hors du commun
aujourd'hui le SAMU Lyon près de 200
personnes dont une quarantaine de
médecins passionnés
arrêt cardiaque
urgent pédiatrique accident de la
circulation je vais vivre au rythme des
urgentistes du SAMU
[Musique]
on est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Lyon et son agglomération la troisième
ville de France compte plus d'un million
d'habitants une population sur laquelle
il faut veiller 7 jours sur 7 24 heures
sur 24
bon ben voilà pour quelques jours au
SAMU de Lyon l'un des plus grands amis
de France et je vais pouvoir approcher
la domotique une facilite le plus le
métier de de médecin urgentiste
l'hôpital Édouard Herriot une ville dans
la ville et quelque part au fond à
gauche le SAMU
c'est Marion qui me reçoit la chef des
infirmières dans les véhicules du Samu
la tenue blanche est obligatoire tant
mieux c'est un vieux fantasme
alors le lundi matin en général j'ai pas
grand chose je vais vous donner vous
avez une ceinture
le docteur House
au boulot chaque matin les médecins de
garde se réunissent pour discuter des
différents cas rencontrer la veille donc
là moi j'ai une patiente
et quelques minutes ou quelques secondes
à 3 4 aspirations
mis sous sac à 9 litres disons que c'est
un peu technique je vais les laisser
continuer entre eux je file dehors
les ambulanciers sont à pied d'oeuvre
l'équipement des 8 véhicules est révisé
chaque jour rien ne doit manquer
matériel de réanimation médicament sans
oublier l'oxygène un mini hôpital de
campagne
consommation d'une semaine ça Fabienne
est la responsable technique des
ambulances
[Musique]
Fabienne
ambulancière comment tu te retrouves
ambulancier ici
c'est longue histoire je suis passé par
tous les postes j'ai d'abord été
permanentiaire au standard pendant 6 ans
donc au décrocher du 15 à la base je
suis aide-soignante un petit peu marre
d'être en service
d'hospitalisation pour changer un peu
besoin
de ça pas de routine non la routine
m'ennuie profondément
et ça je vais vite m'en rendre compte
Fabienne me conduit sur un accident un
enfant de 5 ans et sa mère ont été
renversés par une voiture Fabienne met
le turbo pour rejoindre une équipe du
Samu qui est déjà sur place je vais pas
vous dire que la vitesse où je n'aime
pas
frigo en faisant non
du départ
[Musique]
la difficulté elle est là après c'est
sûr pour l'accès c'est bien plus facile
il y a la difficulté qu'ils ont mis en
même temps les les
[Musique]
comment ça s'appelle les vélos
ça a l'air grave la circulation a été
coupée pompier police et SAMU tout le
monde est là
[Applaudissements]
la mer est clouée au sol
je peux rien vous faire je pourrai pas
venir
son fils de 5 ans se trouve quelques
mètres plus loin
dans un état stable l'enfant est conduit
dans l'ambulance il sera ausculté au
calme
Christian II et médecin urgentiste au
SAMU il doit maintenant gérer la maman
elle se plaint de fortes douleurs au
crâne et à la hanche
il faut d'abord
soulager la douleur et rassurer la dame
avec 33 ans de SAMU Christian s'est géré
ce genre de situation d'accord
j'avais compris si c'était passé
non vous faites pas de souci
on sait pas priori ils ont été renversés
par une voiture qui soit s'est sauvée
soit on sait pas
comprendre ce qui s'est passé c'est le
rôle des policiers
le responsable de l'accident c'est ce
4x4 blanc sa conductrice est en cours
d'interrogation
moment délicat un mauvais mouvement et
on risque d'aggraver les choses
[Musique]
une demi-heure après l'accident la maman
et son enfance sont prêts à être
transportés à l'hôpital mais un petit
détail reste à régler
tout voir une petite minute
[Musique]
la conductrice a pu expliquer les
circonstances de l'accident éblouis par
le soleil elle n'a pas vu les deux
victimes traverser la rue elle les a
percutés elle a même roulé sur la mer
il y a pas l'air d'avoir de les gens
majeurs en tout cas sur l'enfant la dame
je sais pas trop très mal au bassin
alors il est possible que vous auriez
dessus c'est ce qu'on me dit oui vous
allez laisser coincé d'accord donc elle
a probablement une facture au niveau du
bassin oh c'est pas grave ici mais il
faut pas perdre trop je pense pas à
l'hôpital rassurez-vous vous mettez pas
des nouvelles après vous appelez
l'hôpital Édouard Herriot le pavillon
j'ai comme Gérard d'accord mais d'ici
une heure ou deux le temps que c'est moi
qui l'ai renversé sinon vous vous
appelez aucun d'accord et puis vous
demandez le docteur 2 c'est moi comme
j'aurais eu des nouvelles je pourrais
vous en donner d'accord allez si vous
faites pas trop de soucis vous dire ça
pour grand chose
l'ambulance des pompiers est prête à
partir direction les urgences de
l'hôpital Édouard Herriot
[Musique]
ambulancier au SAMU de Lyon depuis 16
ans direction l'hôpital
[Musique]
plus tard nous sommes arrivés
la victime est conduite en salle de
déchocage un service des urgences qui
accueille les cas les plus graves
ici on évalue la situation on pratique
les premiers soins et on engage les
premiers examens
allez c'est bon à 3 1 2 3
une fois déshabillé la patiente est
examinée sous toutes les coutures si la
colonne vertébrale est touchée
elle ne devrait plus sentir ses jambes
on examine les plaies apparentes et
cachées
[Musique]
ça va être là la partie administrative
commence on fait du papier
j'ai l'impression quand même c'est au
niveau du bassin et qu'elle a une
fracture du bassin et ça qui explique à
la si mal et qu'elle est assez
hémorragique ou pas hémorragique déjà là
on sait qu'elle a accent dans l'abdomen
[Musique]
maintenant ils savent plus ils auront le
temps de demander des nouvelles ou bien
ils n'auront pas le temps ils seront
jamais parce qu'il y avait cette dame
maintenant c'est l'hôpital qui s'en
occupe quoi
le scanner révèle racheter la mer une
fracture du bassin et une fracture du
crâne trois mois d'immobilisation
fracture du bassin aussi pour son petit
garçon
[Musique]
retour à la base
tiens
ma femme ce que je fais au boulot
[Rires]
au SAMU dès qu'on a un petit moment de
libre mieux vaut en profiter pour manger
un morceau
[Musique]
et oui ici on mange la même nourriture
que les patients de l'hôpital un régal
alors
[Musique]
j'ai rendez-vous avec le grand patron du
Samu de Lyon le professeur gueugnot
silence
on rentre dans le cœur du Salut Bonjour
Il tient à nous présenter le crâne le
centre de régulation d'appel d'urgence
000 appels chaque année pour 17000
départs d'ambulance par an
salut au revoir
du numéro 15 ce numéro public qui sont
pris en charge par des ce qu'on appelle
les armes les auxiliaires de régulation
médicale ça nous permanentielles qui
décroche et dès qu'il y a un doute sur
une urgence ils vont passer un de nos
médecins régulateurs
urgences qui est donc qui sont donc des
urgentistes spécialisés dans la
l'urgence et la réanimation d'urgence
alors tout le monde y passe parce que on
les a tous vu sur le terrain oui bien
sûr tout le monde tourne et tout le
monde tourne ils ont une activité de
responsabilité une activité clinique de
terrain et une activité de régulation
aujourd'hui l'activité c'est
essentiellement quoi alors notre
activité principale
bon les multiples évidemment mais
l'activité principale c'est
essentiellement du cardiovasculaire
c'est-à-dire c'est les infarctus et les
accidents vasculaires cérébraux et puis
issus de ces pathologies
cardiovasculaires aiguës ben l'évolution
la plus dramatique c'est la ricardiaque
donc tout ce qui tourne autour du coeur
c'est le principal de notre activité les
samues ont été créés en 74 pour traiter
les accidents de la circulation mais
aujourd'hui la route tue beaucoup moins
qu'il y a 40 ans ça ne représente plus
que 20% de l'activité le credo du Samu
en revanche n'a pas changé efficacité
rapidité il a l'air d'envoyer un
hélicoptère là c'est c'est le médecin
régulateur qui prend la décision
d'envoyer un hélicoptère là aussi pour
gagner du un arrêt cardiaque chaque
minute compte un infarctus ça peut
dégénérer un polytraumatisé plus
aggraver etc on a l'habitude de dire et
c'est ce qui passionnant dans notre
métier c'est de traiter la première ce
qu'on appelle en urgence et en
réanimation d'urgence la Golden Hawa
donc en une heure tout se passe quand on
a affaire une détresse vitale tout se
passe sous le principal se passe dans la
première heure la Golden hour l'heure en
or illustration immédiate au départ le
docteur Gilles bagou médecin chef du
centre de régulation un homme vient de
faire un arrêt cardiaque sur un parking
au pied de chez lui
[Musique]
sur les lieux
bonjour le patient a été prise en charge
tout de suite un médecin généraliste du
quartier a démarré le massage cardiaque
quelques minutes seulement après le
malaise
tout de suite si il va sonner qui lui
reparti à un moment il a repris
le massage est pratiqué dans les trois
premières minutes le patient des chances
de s'en sortir jusqu'à 8 minutes ils
peuvent vivre mais gardera sans doute
des séquelles au-delà il est trop tard
on l'éloigne de la scène
continue le massage cardiaque
mais prépare-toi parce que tu vas y
arriver
là et l'adré dans 15 secondes
adresse pour adrénaline une molécule qui
associe au massage cardiaque aide à
redémarrer le cœur
les yeux rivés sur l'électrocardioscope
Gilles commence à faire la grimace il
préfère préparer au pire la femme de ce
monsieur
est très grave on a beaucoup de mal à
faire redémarrer son cœur
c'est pas possible il est plutôt
pessimiste quand même madame
parfait la suivante
et il y a eu strictement aucune
efficacité et
totalement incapable de réagir
donc on va continuer un petit moment
mais je crains que ça ne se termine
et il n'y a pas d'autres possibilités
que l'adrénaline associe au massage
le massage cardiaque dure depuis 40
minutes
aucun redémarrage
bon allez arrête
[Musique]
j'ai même pas embrassé pour lui dire au
revoir quand je suis parti au marché
parce que j'étais persuadé de le
retrouver dans 5 minutes
c'est pas possible
je veux l'embrasser mon dieu c'est une
amende de ma vie ceux qui s'en va
je vais lui dire au revoir je vous
l'embrasser pourquoi tu es parti
maintenant pourquoi pourquoi mon cœur
pourquoi mon ami
je pense que on encaisse pas il faut on
accepte
on accepte les pieds ça fait partie de
la vie
tout simplement on essaie d'être mieux
avec la famille et puis et puis voilà
donc on est juste là pour aider
[Musique]
alors comment on le ressent aussi en
complément de ce que j'ai dit
la semaine dernière c'est un enfant de 3
mois
il y a pas de comparaison peut-être mais
c'est bien pire
voilà
ton urgence
ça va être compliqué
faites tomber sur le dos ok d'accord
je charge en dégage
donc c'est le stress
[Musique]
à peine le temps de boire un café et me
voilà sur la brèche avec Pierre-Yves
dubien le numéro de du Samuel Lyon
médecin urgentiste depuis 24 ans
ça arrive souvent que le patron parte en
intervention oui oui moi souvent que les
autres mais
j'essaie de garder à peu près 50% de mon
activité en activité clinique
je veux pas être
loin du terrain et entre guillemets
diriger une équipe pour la légitimité
donc là on
ferme de 83 ans
[Musique]
une douleur thoracique la routine pour
Pierre-Yves
[Musique]
à toi
oui bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
SAMU est très demandé notre intervention
à nous a lieu dans la rue d'à côté comme
d'habitude les pompiers sont déjà sur
place
on va au 56
c'est déjà une chance parce qu'il y a
l'ascenseur
parce que des fois il est
15 kilos d'ailleurs c'est moi qui dois
le porter allez le sac j'en fais mon
affaire
bonjour
finalement il s'agit d'une insuffisance
respiratoire mais pas seulement
d'accord
la dame souffre aussi d'un éléphantiasis
un grossissement extrême de ses membres
il faut peut-être éviter de la faire
trop marcher là parce que c'est
oui bonjour madame je suis le médecin là
faut pas me crier dessus
ah mais là on va peut-être vous aider
parce que si vous avez du mal à respirer
c'est pas bien de vous faire marcher là
nous ne sommes pas les bienvenus ce
n'est pas cette dame qui a prévenu le
SAMU c'est son infirmière
bonjour madame
je suis le médecin qu'est-ce qui vous
arrive alors
tu peux me passer le stéthoscope s'il te
plaît allez on va respirer
pour vous qui vous faites
c'est vous qui vous faites on va pas
pouvoir vous laisser ici
vous avez votre caractère vous vous
l'avez toujours eu comme ça
oui vous pensez
je pense que ça va être compliqué en
fait vous avez peur de quoi de la maison
de retraite
vous voulez pas y aller
ah oui mais là pour le moment là
vous avez vu comment vous aviez du mal
pour respirer sans oxygène on peut pas
vous laisser à domicile
mais c'est les urgences c'est pas une
hospitalisation
avec votre fauteuil non
les gens les passions effectivement la
possibilité de refuser les soins mais là
du moment où elle est en détresse vitale
on peut pas il va falloir qu'on trouve
une solution donc ça va être ça va être
long à négocier
difficile de la convaincre et
Pierre-Yves ne peut compter ni sur la
famille ni sur le médecin traitant ils
sont injoignables
heureusement exceptionnel un tel refus
en 20 ans je crois que j'en ai jamais
beaucoup
plus de personnes âgées
de nous voir parce que bon à quelqu'un
qui est ouf le fait qu'on puisse le
traiter c'est quand même améliorer ses
symptômes il y a rien de pire que
d'étouffer mais elle elle est
au bout elle est au bout du rouleau
[Musique]
un étouffement qui finit par épuiser
cette dame au point de la rendre plus
docile
l'opération est délicate la dame fait
près de 130 kg
voilà vous êtes mieux là voilà
c'est très bien
après une heure et demie de palabre la
dame est emmenée à l'hôpital ça n'était
pas sa volonté mais sans le SAMU elle
serait morte chez elle
cet homme est atteint le
maximum du maintien à domicile
manifestement donc là
c'est vachement dur humainement quoi
parce que
elle va aller là où elle veut pas aller
c'est à dire
à l'hôpital puis probablement en Soins
de Suite et puis sans doute en maison de
retraite derrière
manifestement elle avait tout organisé
pour pas que ça ait lieu elle avait une
infirmière qui venait deux fois par jour
au service de repas un bip pour appeler
les urgences mais bon
là c'est la détresse des personnes âgées
aujourd'hui isolées
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans le service le personnel
peut se faire vacciner contre la grippe
c'est Marion qui pique et ça se bouscule
j'en profite
[Musique]
qui se dit
on le sent pas effectivement parce
qu'elle fait un petit truc comme ça
merci
[Musique]
je retrouve Pierre-Yves le numéro 2 du
Samu de Lyon
un homme de montagne et de sensations
fortes médecins des policiers d'élite du
GPN
Pierre-Yves est un passionné de
l'urgence
[Musique]
il faut vous sachiez quelque chose pirif
que le métier que vous faites
c'est très exactement le métier que
j'aurais fait c'est vrai
parce que je m'en félidé d'un métier de
rêve
c'est un métier de passion mais qui est
de rêve après
il y a beaucoup de métiers de rêve du
moment où on le fait avec passion j'ai
découvert le SAMU parce que ça fait
toujours un peu ça fait rêver ces
métiers qui bouge beaucoup et c'est un
petit peu dans mon caractère et c'est
vrai que tout de suite ça a été je
dirais entre guillemets le coup de
foudre
dans le milieu médical le SAMU on est un
aristocrate ou au contraire on est
considéré comme un tascheron
alors
j'aime bien votre façon de voir parce
que effectivement je pense qu'on a été
considéré comme des tâcherons longtemps
et aujourd'hui
on est vraiment reconnu je pense aussi
bien par nos pères
que par nos institutions et que par la
population donc il y a eu une montée
de la de l'app de ce métier là quoi tout
à fait
les grands karabats ils pouvaient pas
imaginer au départ pourquoi il avait ils
avaient des confrères qui qui avait
envie de sortir de l'hôpital
toute sirène hurlante
partir sous la pluie va il pouvait pas
comprendre
20h Gilles finit son tour de régulation
ce soir c'est Laurence Raquin qui le
relais médecin urgentiste au SAMU depuis
15 ans elle vient de passer 12 heures en
intervention et enchaîne avec 12 heures
de régulation
[Musique]
bon alors ce que vous avez ce que je te
laisse en stock
plusieurs secondes pas transfert
Lons-le-Saunier mais voilà il y a
surtout longs
[Musique]
qui peut être palpitante
voilà ça commence
oui bonjour le médecin du Samu à
l'appareil
et ça commence par une urgence chez un
nourrisson
[Musique]
donc on part sur un petit câble
pneumothorax et on va aller en niveau 3
pour voir si pour surveillant
parfait on y va
[Musique]
l'enfant est né il y a à peine 5h dans
une clinique dans l'ambulance une
couveuse a remplacer le brancard il y a
Eddy l'ambulancier
Arnaud l'infirmier
et Martine 33 ans de boutique
anesthésiste
énormément d'expérience et qui fait des
caisses de gamme
après seulement
[Musique]
tout le monde la connaît la partie de ça
fait tellement longtemps qu'elle fait de
la pédiatre
un Martine qui était une sommité c'est
une célébrité
[Musique]
je fais partie des célébrités de la
connerie
oui oui
tu veux dire maintenant là
le SAMU n'intervient pas seulement sur
des accidents on est là dans une grande
maternité lyonnaise et le SAMU assure le
transfert des nouveaux-nés d'hôpital à
hôpital bonjour
alors
cet enfant ça va ça va ça va
[Musique]
tout à l'heure 15h 30
le bébé a les bronches encombré
le bébé ne va pas bien et la clinique
dans laquelle il est né n'a pas les
moyens de le prendre en charge ma
formation il faut donc l'amener à
l'hôpital
et donc là on a mis sous sac avec une
petite pipe de façon à ce que il soit
bien oxygène voilà la maman je vais vous
expliquer asseyez-vous oui
donc là quand vous avez accouché comme
il est assez quand même costaud il a un
thorax un peu imposant vous voyez
comment il est un peu macrosone voilà
donc il y avait du mal à passer voilà
donc
on est obligé quand même d'aller emmener
ton petit frère tu l'as vu
tu l'as vu ton petit frère
est-ce que vous croyez en lui laisserai
une bulle
ça va venir
[Musique]
le bébé est prêt à quitter la maternité
il va être transféré en couveuse dans un
hôpital spécialisé en néonatologie
[Musique]
et puis après vous allez aller beaucoup
de cheveux parce que même ça fait
beaucoup de choses dans la journée
tu peux emmener la chaise s'il te plaît
là
[Musique]
voyez maintenant il est mieux là
vous inquiétez pas trop et entre bonnes
mains ils vont s'en occuper
d'accord
allez
[Musique]
on va passer
par là c'est très dur
tu as pris tous les coordonnées des
parents et le bébé sera hospitalisé
plusieurs jours peut-être plusieurs
semaines
au même moment au centre de régulation
du SAMU Laurence a un coup de Bourg
[Musique]
allô il est 22h la nuit est lancée
je vais vous passer au téléphone tout de
suite là vous restez bien au lit jusqu'à
ce qu'il vous réponde parce qu'on a
énormément d'appels
on a plus personne
du tout
et oui le SAMU n'est pas extensible
alors quand tout le monde est sorti
c'est le stress mais en règle générale
on arrive toujours à se débrouiller à
détourner à temporiser un peu c'est pas
c'est extrêmement rare qu'on ne puisse
pas envoyer même de façon différée pour
prendre en charge
ça peut arriver mais c'est rare
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'elles font
toutes nos équipes
[Musique]
Djamila une jeune médecin intervient sur
une chute du deuxième étage
il faut parfois donner de sa personne
[Musique]
deux podcasts un petit miracle après une
chute de 6 mètres
toujours pas
Raphaël lui intervient sur une plaie par
balle
il a pris un plomb en fait
d'accord bonjour monsieur je suis le
médecin
ça n'a pas l'air bien grave le jeune
homme s'en sort avec deux points de
suture
c'est bien compris OK
dernière équipe sur le terrain celle de
David cette fois-ci l'intervention a
l'air nettement plus sérieuse il s'agit
d'un arrêt cardiaque l'homme a secourir
est âgé de 56 ans après avoir grimpé
quatre étages au pas de cours nous
sommes reçus par sa femme
bonjour
c'est quoi les circonstances qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé je suis le médecin
[Musique]
le patient est toujours en vie
une compresse mais son pouls est très
instable stop
lui a permis de reprendre une faible
activité cardiaque le temps que les
secours arrivent
pompiers et médecin travaillent main
dans la main les uns pratiquent le
massage cardiaque les autres mettent en
place le défibrillateur
le défibrillateur peut relancer le cœur
et le stabiliser en envoyant un choc
électrique de près de 300 volts je
charge
[Musique]
voilà pourquoi personne ne doit toucher
le patient
les décharges se succédaient alors
toutes les 5 minutes
[Musique]
on prend le coup
jusqu'à la huitième tentative
quelque chose
le pouls est satisfaisant une première
victoire pour ce patient il est
préférable
le cœur est reparti la tension se
maintient il y avait des petits signes
de réveil il mordait un peu la sonde
voilà il y a quelques signes positifs je
vais pas non plus vous donner des
espoirs surréalistes mais voilà
j'attends la réponse on va sans doute
aller à Saint-Joseph bien sûr madame le
coeur a fonctionne et les pupilles et un
espoir
un espoir qu'il faut entretenir en
allant maintenant le plus vite possible
aux urgences cardiologiques
et les meilleures couleurs que tout
à l'heure les pompiers ont même déployés
la grande échelle
qui peuvent être compatibles avec un
infarctus du myocarde donc on va aller
en cours pour
voir si on peut la déboucher la stntp
c'était bien un infarctus 10 jours plus
tard le patient est sorti de soins
intensifs sans aucune c'est qu'elle
cérébrale sa femme lui a sauvé la vie
mais neuf fois sur dix un arrêt
cardiaque est fatal
retour au SAMU il est minuit après 4
heures à gérer les appels d'urgence
Laurence s'offre une pause
ça fait plus de 16 heures qu'elle est au
boulot
ça fait combien de temps que tu puisses
à tous les départs
on sait on sait on a une feuille où il
est marqué un motif de départ mais on ne
sait jamais ce qu'on va trouver l'idée
de secours c'est un truc important
chez baigné dedans toute petite déjà par
l'intermédiaire de mon père qui était
sapeur-pompiers professionnels donc pas
professionnel volontaire ça existait pas
d'ailleurs des professionnels à l'époque
et donc qui qui était chef d'entreprise
en carrosserie une petite carrosserie de
campagne et qui était appelée voilà la
sirène qui partait qui revenait c'est
dans l'ADN alors voilà donc il y a
peut-être un peu un peu les jeunes qui
parlent moi ce que j'ai pu voir aussi
c'est que c'est un métier super
chronophage et alors toi ça a pas l'air
de te poser un seul problème
[Musique]
voilà oui parce qu'en plus je dors ici
le matin donc
j'entends pas les appels le matin moi je
ferme tout en fait tout est fermé et je
dors et quand je me lève je suis en
forme la nouvelle philosophie de la vie
c'est il y a le boulot puis il y a la
vie
pour rien au monde ça c'est sûr c'est
sûr elle c'est un peu emmêlée les
pinceaux Laurence en fait ce sont trois
tours de 24 heures qu'elle a fait en 5
jours ce qui n'est déjà pas si mal cette
nuit sera calme Laurence pourra même
faire un bout de sieste
lendemain matin cette fois c'est
l'hélicoptère qui est réquisitionné
Florence et son équipe vient d'être
appelé pour un accident de la route
[Musique]
on sait juste qu'il s'agit d'un motard
audrey elle infirmière de l'équipe
direction la campagne a une trentaine de
kilomètres à l'ouest de Lyon le trajet
dure 10 minutes en voiture il aurait
pris plus d'une heure
[Musique]
sur la ligne droite
la colonne vertébrale semble toucher et
lorsqu'on s'approche de la moto on
comprend mieux le réservoir est
totalement éventré le vol plané du
motard impressionne le jeune homme a été
projeté au niveau du panneau gravillon
son dos a heurté la glissière de
sécurité
comme ça est-ce que vous êtes bien jeune
homme
[Musique]
ça sera pour après d'accord quand vous
me direz que tout redémarre bien
[Musique]
il faut être bien bien
on peut le mettre un peu comme ça
j'aimerais bien la tête un peu
et donc il faudra bien vomir là-dedans
est-ce que c'est bon
on est là d'accord on est avec toi
tu as une infirmière et un docteur
[Musique]
l'hélicoptère fait route vers l'hôpital
Édouard Herriot avec une colonne
vertébrale touchée chaque minute compte
[Musique]
une compression de la colonne vertébrale
un tassement des vertèbres
d'après les gendarmes ce jeune motard
roulait à plus de 120 km/h lorsqu'il a
heurté la voiture de plein fouet
à peine atterri le patient est emmené en
salle de déchaussage
[Musique]
2 3 au niveau des 10 il a quand même
bien mal donc là il vient d'avoir un peu
de morue
[Musique]
quasi immédiatement quoi dans 2 minutes
après le déchocage le scanner les
médecins recherchent des anomalies
invisibles sur les radios
et les résultats
sont sans appel
bonjour
deux des vertèbres dorsales sont
fracturées
là tu vois c'est plus joli rond et si on
continue là tu vois c'est pareil et
c'est là où il y a la moelle donc tu
vois tu as les morceaux ils rentrent
dans la moelle et là c'est tout péter là
donc là ils vont envoyer les images au
neuro share et vont lui demander ce
qu'on peut faire si on peut faire
quelque chose
bon salut cocoon le petit gars
à bientôt
[Musique]
il faut pas rouler trop vite
il y a plein de motards
[Musique]
le jeune motard passera 6 heures au bloc
opératoire les neurochirurgiens
confirmeront la paraplégie la paralysie
des membres inférieurs
retour à la base de l'hélico du SAMU
aujourd'hui Florence ne repartira pas en
intervention
[Musique]
c'est la vie on peut pas porter toute la
misère du monde c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible sinon soit bien praticien
stressé soit soit
[Musique]
addictif je sais pas enfin ça peut être
dangereux quoi si tu prends tout pour
toi ça peut être extrêmement dangereux
pour la personne pour la destruction
interne
j'ai envie de
réussir ma vie de réussir voilà de vivre
bien tout ce que je vis à l'instant
parce que voilà tu sais que les choses
elles peuvent disparaître du jour au
lendemain
aujourd'hui pour Arnaud c'est la quille
après 10 années de Samus et ça ça rose
[Musique]
bon séjour aussi touche à sa fin
je me dis que c'est le genre de lettre
évidemment qui que tout le monde attend
parce que le tracé rare
bonjour mesdames Messieurs le 31 mai
vous êtes intervenu suite à l'appel des
pompiers pour mon époux qui était au
plus mal vous lui avez sauvé la vie en
le mettant dans un service au top avec
des médecins infirmiers aide-soignants
très bien simplement remerciement je ne
vous oublierai jamais voilà ça c'est le
genre de lettre évidemment
il y a marqué le nom des gens qui sont
intervenus dessus Patrick Franquet
Alexandre évidemment il doit être
vachement content c'est des petits trucs
qui font
qui font plaisir sans doute
son mari
et ben non il est pas mort
ça sert
[Musique]
bon il faut que je me sauve j'avais rêvé
de ce métier quand j'étais mort cette
semaine m'a confirmé que j'avais bien
raison
il est temps pour moi de repartir à la
découverte de nouveaux horizons ou
m'attendent d'autres hommes d'autres
femmes au métier exceptionnel
[Musique]